aquí se ven todos los componentes que
vamos a usar con nuestra beats y voz
aunque ustedes pueden usar otros
elementos y de hecho los invito a que lo
intenten lo único que ustedes sí deben
de tener es el arduino todo lo demás
puede ser reemplazado por otras cosas
podemos usar otro tipo de baterías
diferentes motores etcétera vamos a ver
los productos que tengo aquí y de donde
los obtuve o de dónde vinieron y después
comenzaremos a ensamblar a bits y bots
para que vean cómo lo hacemos si no
tienen dos secadoras de cabello que
puedan desarmar pueden comprar un par de
motores eléctricos y ruedas para estos
hay muchas cosas que podemos hacer para
resolver este problema nosotros usamos
dos motores de secadora de cabello aquí
pueden ver el ventilador abajo de estos
tenemos una hoja de plástico lexan
resistente en la cual es fácil hacer
agujeros y que vamos a usar para el
montaje de algunos de nuestros
dispositivos lo pueden conseguir en la
ferretería es un plástico transparente
de policarbonato y la marca es lexan
aquí
es un control remoto universal que
pueden comprar en tiendas de
electrónicos lo vamos a usar para
controlar a nuestra beats y bot tenemos
cinta aislante negra y diferentes cables
de calibre 22
tenemos soldadura para hacer nuestras
conexiones eléctricas como lo hicimos en
el vídeo dónde armamos y soldamos el
controlador del motor
este es el controlador del motor que nos
permitirá ajustar la dirección y
velocidad de nuestros motores este es
nuestro arduino y es un microcontrolador
en donde conectaremos y controlaremos
los diferentes elementos es una
computadora en la que descargamos código
para que funcione el controlador de
motor y las demás cosas de la forma que
queremos
esta es una tableta de prototipos y
veremos cómo cablear la y cómo
conectarle diferentes componentes
electrónicos
este es nuestro módulo de grabadora
digital que usaremos para grabar y
reproducir sonidos vamos a usar el
arduino para activarlo y así nuestro
robot podrá reproducir sonidos o
grabarlos cuando se mueva
aquí tenemos baterías dobles y 1
la caja para baterías las baterías
tienen 1.5 volts cada una pero al
conectarlas en serie tendremos 12 volts
lo que será genial para nuestros motores
ya que funcionan con un voltaje mayor a
1.5 volts aquí tenemos diferentes
transistores que vamos a usar como
interruptores para nuestros circuitos
tenemos leds de tres colores también
tenemos tornillos tuercas y resistencias
de 330 oms 10.011 y 220 11 más adelante
veremos esto con más detalle y aquí está
la tableta de nuestro reloj despertador
ya que usaremos algunos de sus
componentes por acá tenemos una cafetera
o mejor dicho una jarra de cafetera ya
que también usaremos algunos de sus
componentes para bits y aquí pueden ver
unas cintas para sujetar o cinchos
también vamos a necesitar un sensor
infrarrojo para visión y nos va a servir
para recibir las señales del control
remoto
se ve así así que vamos a necesitar uno
de estos